first
God
I think about you to the days in the
time that we had
the stupid things you said we were two
birds of paradise la la la
two
do forgive me up a sale leave
hey you go you bad [ __ ] happy
sunday it's the lord's day you're
showing up with a big Jesus dick and a
[ __ ] top hat who's better than
you oh joy with a fucked-up hairdo
belugas a [ __ ] about a handle it's
what's in your heart what's between your
legs let's [ __ ] crack a lackin
[ __ ] as usual smoking the best
[ __ ] weed in cali some [ __ ]
ask me s Li youyou Rogan should it came
to Rotterdam to smoke some good weed you
had 18 22 [ __ ] hours to do one the
hell with a bunch of Gentiles making
believe I'm sitting over here smoking
[ __ ] go with a blue number four and
you want me to go to rather than you
[ __ ] [ __ ] these people
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
I've been singing in a couple days
figured I'd touch anyhow the Lord's they
went to church got holy [ __ ]
sacrament and now I'm ready to sling
dick with a crucifixion this damage
slinging deck what a crucifix that's the
word of the day beside that it's
Mother's Day happy mother's day doll my
girls cleo is spooky or you mother's
work if I don't remember you know I love
you till the [ __ ] that you bad
[ __ ] I live through you guys
I'll a mom my mum punch the ticket but I
keep [ __ ] swinging like a savage
because I got you guys I lived with
osmosis Joey which was Jenna Jenna let's
bar some [ __ ]
me show you some any 80s somebody gave
you a good [ __ ] weed they gave it to
you all these canisters last night a
dear friend came up to me with one of
these [ __ ] canisters you see a label
you see this is death making all these
black things this is debt this is what
the [ __ ] Nazis carry understand we're
about to smoke some with his [ __ ]
briefing I smoked some last night my god
oh yeah and now I share with you
[ __ ] you know why that's not
love yeah that's why I kept acrylic glue
and some other [ __ ] inside bellowing
deeper than deep look at this [ __ ]
beautiful he said he grew this little
[ __ ] astronaut suit on that's how
strong distance i'm saying i'm here with
you guys to tell you i love you go give
you a mother big [ __ ] hug I got no
mother but if I did I wouldn't be out
here with you [ __ ] jerk los [ __ ]
around understand happy inside robbing
my mother's feet so I suggest you do the
same vocals by love you that's no
solution
nice smooth right let's get the [ __ ]
Pope real life and smushed issued in it
under this [ __ ] bad boy that the
church tomorrow night I don't know what
I don't know what I feel there's you get
to attend su Jin to a 12 I got the Wi-Fi
have the kids I'm thinking maybe I
should just do a little like at about
working on the house and have a protein
drink right ketchup on my right for the
week you know a lot of options but now
really but this route why not try
calabaza get I will you mother funds
before the ER your mom's house to eat oh
he meatballs alota [ __ ] did they eat
somebody [ __ ] too you know me always a
good thing somebody's monkey so that's
on your mind who am I to stand in your
way
sometimes getting some bees buzzing just
a boy the point is that you're a [ __ ]
Savage that you don't give a [ __ ] you go
deep in that monkey and suck on her
[ __ ] kidney Val I don't give a [ __ ]
that day you [ __ ] on stopped my
[ __ ] meet up please don't forget
don't forgive me is how I like I don't
like digging around I don't want to
smoke a bunch of people giggling you
know if my friend at the store go [ __ ]
yourself I do a professional's I would
have bleep different level maybe there's
smoke reefer we want to call the heads
you know I had it been a great 10 not
all we want to do is smoke [ __ ] that's
all I don't give a [ __ ] about what you
have to say no when you don't want to do
floors I got a refill get this but
jumping jack do little stretching maybe
have some oatmeal turn this into a
birthday you know what by law if I was
on the other jerk off on the street I'd
be sad today hold and her mother look at
the people of hug they don't give a [ __ ]
I don't have a mother I'll see in the
next life I'm saying to live is to be
sleeping to die is to be [ __ ] away
I've seen that the Indian tola bombala
yesterday on TV beautiful town in Mexico
and I go to Mexico from time to time to
talk those [ __ ] bluehost
that's a straight [ __ ]
I'm start explain a [ __ ] so he said we
smoke one more what he wanted my sign
talk to [ __ ] boring people or you
want a hammer a we uncle Joey and burn
one more then we think as do one more
how to respect if I took the time to
come out here you gotta smoke what law
would make us on York and say I don't
demand them from you as your uncle did I
ever say you're gonna work you're
delicious Oh somebody's dick no love
that's it that's my [ __ ] that all
about you it's all about my family it's
all about your mother's be good hug him
like I said I don't have a mom but I
know my mom was alive I know I'd be
[ __ ] dreaming [ __ ] so do your thing
today you know don't let nobody [ __ ] me
you know me you're lean your own [ __ ]
primary line of them that's me some
people gotta [ __ ] this day I got my
own private island we know it is and I
from my head to my heart straight down
to my top or better yet to my ball sack
I was tickled madam much fear I'm
[ __ ] scared of everything I am a now
I might convince myself like him last
night i'm only gonna come I was scared
out of somebody's my kid who [ __ ]
knows but I go down a dog I don't you
[ __ ] I do what gives me feel young sayin
like whatever scares me I [ __ ] do I
love you juju I can my fat [ __ ] I can't
breathe down your [ __ ] I do not act as
the more I go it's good for the soul
trust me
anybody can show up when you're good at
something sharper your marathon and try
to get yourself good way through so many
people make understand up game ain't no
Belinelli ain't no better than these
dude i just kept showing up Annabeth you
crack jokes you see the town you go to
our nation's people bumpy home is a [ __ ]
it's something you smoke weed yo hug
your family you get the catechist like
we call the dog a bone by him
as usual wanna be a bother to you people
listen I don't give a [ __ ] about
McGregor I'm your [ __ ] about the you see
I'm give a [ __ ] bucknell oh I didn't get
out here to talk to you about Kevin
advance I came out here to talk to you
[ __ ] about life and how we're
gonna [ __ ] it up today that's all
anything else I'm comfy I give a [ __ ]
about McGregor I'll give a [ __ ] dog
Apple that [ __ ] doesn't even cross my
mind I'm not even into it no I meant to
you [ __ ] beat selfish that's it
yeah I owe me a service to my friend get
the [ __ ] off periscope and go starbucks
huh that movie was so get the [ __ ] out
that's it i'm totally guilty
I'll check in with you [ __ ]
later you know you know I don't forget
about you again I have a happy Mother's
Day give your mother a hug tell uncle
Joey sends her love I'll see you
[ __ ] tomorrow I see you
tomorrow on this motion [ __ ]
tremendous with another batch of
Skywalker inside there's what they
[ __ ] gave the devil he made an
appearance on the tonight show anyway I
love you mother [ __ ] stay black have
a good day I thought I'm with the Orion
that demon come on my till I being a
holy oil hey Gillman